PROFESSOR: Cardinality
is the word
that's used to refer to
the size of infinite sets.
And before we go further,
let's take a quick look
at why we're interested
in infinite sets
in a course that's Mathematics
for Computer Scientists.
Why does computer science
care about infinite sets?
Well, like every data
structure that you'd
examine in computer
memory is finite
and the integers
individually are finite,
you only calculate
with finite things.
But, the infinite abstraction
happens right at the beginning.
Although any given integer is
finite, the set of all integers
is infinite.
And although any given
matrix is finite,
the set of all the
matrices that might
be represented in a computation
are an infinite set.
So, we take infinite sets
for granted and reason
about them all the time.
The second, from a
pedagogical point of view,
introducing the concept
of infinite sets
and reasoning about
them carefully
forces you to go
beyond your intuition
and really follow
the rules and reason
in a careful mathematical way.
Because although some properties
that you're familiar with from
finite sets carry over to
infinite sets, others don't.
And in order to
know which is which,
you have to be thinking
carefully about the rules
and properties that
they have, as opposed
to just going by intuition
and familiar properties.
And finally, the
reasoning that goes
into comparing the sizes
of infinite sets, which
is the topic of today's video,
has profound implications
in computer science
because it leads
to the insight about the
logical limits of computation
and examples of
specific problems
that computers can't
solve, which we'll
be taking up in a later video.
But for now, let's go back
to the topic of cardinality.
So, there was this mathematician
in the late 19th century
named Cantor who was actually
working on Fourier's series.
And he discovered that
the kind of series
that he was working
with diverged
in infinitely many places,
which sounds kind of bad.
But he wanted to
get across the idea
that it didn't diverge in
very many infinite places.
And that led him to
this idea of comparing
the sizes of infinite sets.
So, this is Cantor's idea.
We know from the mapping
dilemma that if you're
looking at finite sets A
and B, then the size of A
is greater than or
equal to the size of B
if and only if A
surj B, were surj
is this technical relation which
means there exists a surjection
function from A to B that
is a function with greater
than or equal to one arrow
into every element of B.
And Cantor's idea
was saying, well,
it works fine for finite sets.
Why don't we take this as the
definition of what we mean by A
is at least the size
of B for infinite sets?
So, we're going to
think of A surj B
now as saying, A is as big
as B. And for finite sets,
it's literally true that A surj
B if and only if the size of A
is greater or equal
to the size of B.
Now, let me take a moment to
say that this notion of size
or cardinality, when you're
talking about infinite sets,
it's kind of a no-no.
There's an abstract concept of
what cardinal numbers are, what
these infinite numbers are.
But the truth is, they're
technical and not of very much
use.
So, we will never actually be
talking about the cardinality
or size of an infinite set.
But what we will
do is compare them.
We're going to have a nice
elementary theory of the idea
that the cardinality
of one set is
greater than or equal to the
cardinality of another set.
And the basic definition is
going to be based on surj.
Similarly, bijection
is even easier.
A bij B means that there's
a bijection from A to B.
And we're going
to interpret that
as saying that A and
B are the same size.
That is, for finite sets,
it literally means A
and B have the same
number of elements.
We're going to adopt the
notion of a bijective relation
for infinite sets as meaning, I
don't know what their size is,
but I know it's the
same because there's
a bijection between them.
There's a perfect one to one
correspondence between As
and Bs.
Let's look at an example of
where bijection comes up.
The power set of N-- if N is
the non-negative integers--
the power set of N
is all the subsets
of non-negative integers.
And let me just remark that
there is an obvious bijection
between the subsets of integers
and the infinite bit-strings,
the infinite strings
of zeroes and ones.
So, N is the set of
non-negative integers, 0, 1, 2.
If you take any subset of
N, here's one with has 0,
missing 1, has 2 and
3, missing 4, 5, has 6,
and so on, then what I can do
is represent such a subset,
possibly an infinite subset
now, by an infinite sequence
of ones and zeros.
Put in ones in the position
where elements in the subset
occur and zeroes in positions
where elements don't occur.
This was exactly
the same bijection
that we had found between the
non-negative-- the bit-strings
and the finite subsets of
the non-negative integers.
But now, we're just extending
it to arbitrary subsets
of the non-negative integers.
So, this defines a
bijection between any subset
of integers corresponds to
an infinite bit-strings.
And conversely, from
any infinite bit-string,
you can reconstruct what
subset it refers to.
So, we use this notation
[? 0,1 ?] to the omega,
meaning the infinite bit-strings
that are infinite to the right.
They have a beginning.
In comparison to [? 0,1 ?]
superscript star,
which refers to the finite
sets of bit-strings.
So now, let's examine the
standard size properties
that you would expect if these
relationships of surj and bij
behaved like relationships
between sizes.
So, one basic property
that finite sizes have
is that if A is equal to B
and B is equal to C in size,
then the size of A and the
size of C are the same.
That's certainly
true for finite sets.
Does it hold for infinite
sets, where now equality is
going to be replaced by bij?
Well, we have to check it.
Is it true that if A bij B and
B bij C implies A bij C, well,
how do you prove that?
Well, it's true, and here's how.
By definition,
since A bij B, that
means that you have a
bijection g from A to B.
And since B bij C, you have a
bijection f from B to C. Now,
I need from these two
bijections that I'm
given, I need to find a
bijection between A and C.
Well, that's easy.
What you do is you use
g to go from A to B,
and then you use f to go from
B to C. And you compose them,
and that gives you the needed
bijection from A to C. So,
define h to be the
composition of f and g.
And it's easy to check that if
g and f are bijections, then
their composition
is a bijection.
So, that's how I find the needed
bijection from A to C. So,
this property works
out just fine.
The similar property applies
to at least as big as,
greater than or equal to.
For finite sets, if A is
greater than or equal to B
and B is greater than
or equal to C in size,
then A is greater
than or equal to C.
And actually, the same
argument that worked for bij
works for surj,
because the composition
of surjective functions
is a surjective function.
So, if A surj B and B
surj C implies A surj C.
Now again remember, although
we're thinking of surj
as meaning greater than
or equal to in size,
you cannot take these size
properties for granted.
They have to be proved.
Surj has a technical
definition having
to do with surjective functions,
functions with greater
than or equal to one arrow in.
That is not the same as
talking about equality
of some kind of sizes.
Well, let's look at an example
where the size properties hold
but they're less obvious.
Because here's another
familiar size property.
If A and B are each
of size greater than
or equal to the other one,
then they're the same size.
So, if the size of A is greater
than or equal to the size of B
and the size of B is greater
than or equal to the size of A,
then A and B are the same size.
Now, this is certainly
true for finite sets.
It's kind of, you don't
even think about that fact.
And it holds for infinite sets.
But, it's not so obvious.
So, what we're saying is that
if I have a surjective function
from A to B and I have another
surjective function from B
to A, then there's a
bijection between A and B.
And the problem here is that
this surjection from A to B
might not be a bijection.
And this surjection from B to A
might also not be a bijection.
So, where's the bijection
going to come from?
I have to build it.
And so, this is not an
obvious property, it's true.
It's called the
Schroeder-Bernstein Theorem.
And the trick, basically, is you
take the bijection from A to B
and the bijection from B to
A and you take parts of one
and combine it with
parts of the other.
And in a slightly
ingenious way that
actually is contained in
a problem in the text,
you can find the
bijection from A to B,
but it does take a
little bit of ingenuity.
So this is a size property
that works for surj and bij,
but you can't say it's obvious.
Well, let's look at an
unfamiliar size property.
Something that's not
true of finite sets
where we have to start being
careful and not just hand wave
and use our intuition
about finite sets.
Namely, for infinite sizes,
size plus 1 is equal to size.
Now, what exactly
does that mean?
Well, let's just illustrate
it with an example.
In fact, in some ways,
you can the definition
of an infinite set is
that its size plus 1
is equal to its size.
Let's look at a simple example.
So, on the bottom, I have
the non-negative integers.
And on the top, I have
the positive integers.
So, I can get from
the positive integers
to the non-negative integers
just by throwing in zero.
So, that's where the
plus one comes from.
Here's a nice infinite set.
I add another element to it,
and I get another infinite set,
but they are the same size.
I have to show a
bijection between them
to show they're the set size.
Well, you know what
the bijection is.
Map 0 to 1, 1 to 2, 2 to 3.
This is a bijection which you
know as the add one function.
The add one function maps
the non-negative integers
to the positive integers,
and it's a perfect bijection.
Therefore, adding one element
to the non-negative integers--
to the positive integers
does not get me a larger set,
it gets me another
set of the same size.
And this argument
actually generalizes
to any infinite set.
If you throw in
one extra element,
you could still find a bijection
between the original set
and the set with
one extra element.
So, N is the same size
as the positive integers.
Well, in fact, let's
look at this one.
I can enumerate on the
top all the integers,
both positive and negative.
0, 1, minus 1, 2,
minus 2, and so on.
And that gives me the set
consisting of all the integers.
And over here, I
can have 0, 1, 2,
just the non-negative integers.
And you can see the
orderly way in which I've
listed the integers at the top.
That implicitly
defines a bijection.
I'm going to map zero to the
zeroeth element of the sequence
above.
1 to 1, 2 to minus 1,
3 to 2, 4 to minus 2.
And in this way, I
have actually defined
a bijection between the
non-negative integers and all
the integers.
In other words, you take
half of the integers, namely
the non-negative
integers, and it's still
the same size as all of them.
There's a bijection
between N and Z.
Now, you could write
a formula, actually,
if you were trying to figure out
what does the number N go to?
What positive or
negative integer?
There's some not very
hard formula involving
dividing N by two and rounding.
But, that doesn't matter.
Once I've figured
out some sensible way
to list all the elements
of the integers in a row,
then I can wind them up against
the non-negative integers.
And that listing, in
effect, defines the mapping
in a perfectly clear way without
necessarily having a formula.